the cage is so iconic
it was uh you know it was exciting to be
in there it's super iconic we both have
done bad things i wanted to move here so
that we could start noon
congratulations you two have both
survived your first season of you
yes thank you kindly thank you very much
did you know from when you signed on
that you would pull through or did that
become news to you as filming went on i
knew uh sarah gave me the pitch
beforehand and she let me know that
that's how it was going to end and it
just added fuel to my fire it really
gave me some freedom to push carrie to
those limits
uh and because i knew i'm getting out
alive at the end yeah okay so as a fan
of the show
lauren i wanted to die i wanted to die
in dramatic fashion so when sarah told
me no darling you're gonna stay alive it
really helped me like think about like
throughout the filming like what is the
why behind this like why does this
couple because we're the first caged
couple right we make history but why
does this couple get to survive and
through the filming and and all the
twists and turns and the things that you
learn about joe and love's relationship
and sharing carrie's relationship and
how they operate i got it i i understood
why
for you
i'd move to some solar suburb come
latter with us you're the first couple
to be trapped in that glass cage what an
honor what is it like to film those
scenes it's terrible
and it was confining and you know we got
to shoot it in consecutive order so it
was kind of felt like we were filming a
play where it as an actor you normally
don't shoot things sequentially so we
got to do this moment by moment and
really build it and it was we were i was
ready to get the hell out of the cage
let me tell you but it was definitely
the cage is so iconic
it was uh you know it was exciting to be
in there it's super iconic but the thing
that i didn't consider until
literally like right before we filmed in
rehearsal was that how long i would have
to be in that confined space and i don't
like that i don't like being in confined
spaces and god love travis but i don't
like being in confined spaces with other
humans so i was like really
uncomfortable with the idea so yes i too
was ready to go and i allowed my very
real feelings to fuel sherry's angst and
she got to take out her frustration on
me there's a moment where she gets to
slap me a couple times and so i feel
like i think that's where the
frustration came out and my response to
the end of the season is winning this
came sooner than expected
marriage isn't really built for secrets
by the way what's it like on set because
there's some violent scenes in this show
as the newbies on set what was it like
for you when you kind of had to walk
away at the end of the day or film some
of those tough scenes and maybe leave it
behind like how did you guys unwind and
bond as a cast well i uh my like unwind
the thing that i choose to do to unwind
and also stay in shape is that i do
russian exotic pole dance so i i owned a
house in la and i sold it after we uh
finished but i had a pole studio in my
house and there were some scenes where i
came home and i was still so buzzed that
i had to dance i had to dance it out get
myself so tired so that i could go to
sleep chelita you got to bring the rest
of the cast in on this i want some you
pool dance parties
easily
i'm ready i'm ready
uh travis i'll go to you for this one
you guys did have to shoot with you know
covid on the mind and again it's a very
intimate show so what was that like to
do some of those very close scenes it
was a lot of protocol i think that we
had to follow with kobet you had to
remain distant from each other you
didn't see a lot of the crew's face
until the very end of the shoot so that
was a little jarring to actually go like
that oh that's what you look like
but for the most part we would rehearse
with our masks off and so we were really
i feel like when it came to the acting
the covet stuff really didn't get in the
way it felt like it was just just normal
filming on his set so i'm pretty
grateful for that
things will be different this time
you